la decisión de joe biden enfureció a la
industria farmacéutica el presidente
estadounidense ha apoya la propuesta que
países como india y sudáfrica han
presentado ante la organización mundial
del comercio y que pretende suspender
temporalmente las patentes de las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 y así dar un
acceso más fácil a las dosis en todo el
mundo la representante de comercio
exterior de eeuu catering time hizo el
anuncio a través de un comunicado esta
es una crisis de salud mundial y las
circunstancias extraordinarias de la
pandemia de kobe 19 exigen medidas
extraordinarias la administración cree
fuertemente en la protección de la
propiedad intelectual pero para acabar
con esta pandemia apoyamos la extensión
de las protecciones para las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 la decisión fue
aplaudida por el director de la ms este
es un momento monumental en la lucha
contra el 19 el compromiso de joe biden
y katrin type de respaldar la exención
de la protección de la propiedad
intelectual en las vacunas es un
poderoso ejemplo del liderazgo de eeuu
para abordar los desafíos de salud
global
tras el anuncio de byd en las acciones
de los fabricantes de vacunas modernas y
nobacs cayeron en el comercio regular y
las de facer cayeron levemente el sector
farmacéutico reaccionó rechazando una
posible suspensión de las patentes las
farmacéuticas asegura que se trata de
una decisión errónea e hicieron un
llamado para lograr mejores acuerdos de
transferencia de tecnología desde que
empezó el desarrollo de la vacuna contra
el coronavirus las farmacéuticas han
reportado millonarios ingresos y
ganancias con la declaración de wyden se
abre el camino para lo que podrían ser
meses de negociaciones para elaborar un
plan de extensión específico pero es una
decisión que requiere el consenso de los
164 países miembros de la organización
mundial del comercio